let's get to the other game that wasn't
supposed to be in prime time on monday
even though five o'clock really is and
it was supposed to be the thursday night
game because the bills played the titans
last tuesday because of a coveted
rescheduling here we are with a thursday
night game that was in that five o'clock
to eight o'clock window eastern on a
monday and
ish
uh the bills chris you know and it
it really
it really felt good to be right about
something last night to be right about
both games last night after that sunday
bloodbath where i had to go back and
reevaluate
my my limited prognostication skills but
you know the cheese got knocked wobbly
by a team that they took lightly the
bills
i think got knocked into thinking maybe
we're not that good and after last night
especially on defense
i think it's fair to say the bills
aren't that good well no they're not
mike i've you know i've been saying this
to you that their defense has got issues
it's got big time issues they can't rush
the passer they can't stop the run
therefore they are screwed as what you
saw last night and you know the bigger
picture is
you know i first off a few things you
said there yeah the bills aren't ready
for prime time they're not on the level
of the tennessee titans of the kansas
city chiefs that's very obvious no doubt
about that and then you know you talk
about some of what the chiefs did it
seemed like the focus was there but man
that was really cool to see the chiefs
and take them taking that approach last
night you know if they can bring that
element to their offense to where you
really have to worry about that run game
and clyde edward zelaire and all of that
to go along with everything else we know
their offense can do i mean they'll be
unstoppable i've never seen andy reid be
that patient that way that was very very
impressive uh from from his standpoint
and yeah you the bills josh allen i
think josh allen was extra nervous with
patrick mahomes and that whole you know
talk and everything like that and uh it
showed it showed in their play and
they're sloppy and they're not on the
level of the super bowl champion kansas
city chiefs no way
and and here's my real question moving
forward have the chiefs unlocked some
next level to their offense where
they're back to the 70s and they're
going to run the ball and run the ball
and there were 26 carries by edward
zelaire mahomes ran it 10 times daryl
williams got involved with six carries
they got le'veon bell coming or was it
just
looking at the film saying man
run defense stinks let's just let's just
run it down their throats all night long
until they stop us well i mean i think
it is a little of that first off
i do think to your first question right
i think it's something kansas city
realizes they need to have there for
just in case wait are teams going to
keep playing us with these deep zones
like the raiders with the deep zones and
whoa way down the field and man-to-man
coverage and eight people in coverage
and only three man rushes so i think
they realized teams might play us like
that we can't let them get away with it
we gotta start to grow that part of our
offense and the underneath pass game and
things like that so andy reid smart i
think he real he realized that you know
the i can't remember what the second
part or where i was going to go there
with the rest of my uh convo there how
much of it is the bills oh the bill's
so bad let's just run it well yes and i
think the bill's defense
you know last week we saw they had a
sellout to stop the run they let up easy
touchdown passes to ryan tannehill i
think that you know if ryan tannel
doesn't have short short fields last
week they're going to throw for big
yards the bills are compromised they
have to sell out in one area when the
offense is really talented to stop that
one area and last night what did they do
they went damn we're gonna play deep
we're gonna drop back we can't play
man-to-man and we're gonna play deep
zones and therefore that's where andy
reid crushed them right there because
okay you want to do that they move them
around up front there's not any good
defense alignment on the bills and they
have real issues on that side of the
ball
what do you think happened to the bill's
defense this year
where has that where has the decline
come from well they're they're like
jerry jerry hughes and the pass rush
have not really
shown itself at all you see they benched
like trent murphy a guy who they got in
free agency two years ago they made him
inactive for the game he's been
non-existent on the field ed oliver
their top 10 pick from the 2019 draft
has been underwhelming to this point of
his career you know and then they lost
some role players and have a few
injuries there right now that's hurting
them as well but mike what makes it even
worse is they don't have they don't play
man-to-man and they don't have
man-to-man corners they can't they can't
ask true davious white and josh norman
to lock down people and get an island
that's not what they do they play zone
that so they're really in a tough spot
that way and that's why when you see
josh allen after the game go i can't
play like that or you know because they
can't win unless the offense and josh
allen kind of set the pace of the
football game and put the pressure on
the other team for therefore they have
to kind of play out of their comfort
zone and i think that's what we've come
apparent the last two weeks with the
buffalo bills
and i think all those long drives by the
chiefs just make it harder for josh
allen and you press a little bit more
when you finally get on the field one of
the formulas we talk about for taking
the steam out of a good offense keep it
on the sideline drinking gatorade as you
say and i think there's a lot more
urgency and anxiety when they finally
get on the field no urgency or anxiety
though for the chiefs offense let's hear
from clyde edwards elaire and patrick
mahomes on this new look
uncharacteristic andy reed running game
i think this is the first time you guys
have run for more than you've thrown for
what was it like uh resisting the
temptation to take shots downfield and
uh stuff like that
yeah it was definitely different i mean
i had a few of those rpos called and i
had to have to tell myself not to throw
it just keep handing that thing off i
mean the clyde was running well i was
blocking well and uh i mean i just want
to win i don't care how that's done you
have days like this things just seem you
know like to support like the red sea
and that's what the o-line did and
ultimately i just put my head down and
run and then when it's time to make a
guy [ __ ] or time to run through a guy i
do my job that fires up the whole line
and and i'm doing my 111 so ultimately
it got us the win
you know i just wonder how much the
looming arrival of le'veon bell
put a put a red hot poker on clyde
edwards because
we look back at his performances last
week he set the narrative week one when
he has that big night and since then he
has not been great
and now here comes le'veon bell
and clyde edward zelaire looks better
than he ever has and and that's good hey
maybe it's good to have that that
one-two punch a little competition
in-house a little you better go out
there and not be complacent and keep
going and keep going because we got
somebody else we'll put in if you're not
on it tonight i i think so i mean you
know you can put them both on the field
you can both split them at receiver
they're going to be able to do a lot of
different things one yeah is a little
bit more speed and make you miss based
le'veon bell of course has that make you
miss factor but he's a big human being
and he can run you over he's certainly a
lot bigger than clyde edward zeller i
mean le'veon bell is one of those guys
when you see him in person you go whoa
you're a little bigger than i thought
you were i didn't realize you were this
tall and you know quite this long and
everything like that that way so that
could be a tremendous combination and
and the other thing and i think you know
troy aikman and joe buck kind of talked
about this last night i mean damn they
just they can't kill clyde edwards
hilaire before the season ends you know
he can't do everything he can't catch
every screen and run the ball every time
so i think they got to be they're aware
of that too to where they don't want to
ruin the guy's career before he gets to
year three and just you know grinding
him in the ground but man good for him i
mean that was a unbelievable performance
by him andy reid i just can't say enough
about him i mean it's 20 years we've
never seen him do that of being one of
the best play callers there is and i
just think it shows he's willing to grow
and he's starting to go man my team's
special
and i'm just going to do whatever i got
to do this week to win this game and i
think he's starting to get some of that
about him and i think it's cool to see
because the chiefs are really really
damn good
mahomes mentioned the run pass option
plays and
number one for reed to even include the
run as an option and number two from our
homes
to become patient enough i remember last
year going into the 2019 season after
he'd won the mvp award
i can't remember in what setting i
talked to him but there was the question
about
what do you do
to counter the defenses and he said i
know what's going to happen now they're
going to be deep they're going to be
back and i'm going to have to be more
patient i have to find a way to be more
patient well this is the ultimate test
of patience when you just hand the ball
off when you know
that you
if you didn't hand the ball off would
still have a pretty good chance to make
it happen something happened through the
air but you're taking the easier more
conservative more sure thing and the run
is there so hand off and go and and it's
just part of the overall development
maturity of patrick mahomes as a
quarterback agreed well he's just he's
just not a he's not a greedy guy
he's not he just never never seems to be
in any sense of you know as a football
player or as a human being he just went
well why why why why try to jam a rpo
slant in between some safety and a
linebacker when we're just ripping off
five and six yards at a time it's the
maturity of him you know and again it's
it's why he he doesn't throw
interceptions a lot i mean he just he
knows how to play the position let alone
he has this rare freaky talent and
that's amazing it really is but the
chiefs you know i think we talked about
this a few weeks ago just the
physicality of their football team once
again it kind of gets overlooked because
of the high-flying mahomes aspect but
their defense steamrolled the bill's
offensive line josh allen was in trouble
all night from the get-go he was always
having to throw balls off the back of
his foot and do that chris jones is a
force and then their ability to just
play smash mouth on the offensive line
wow i mean if they can get that going
man they're going to be unstoppable
yeah and uh look just to put one last
pin in it patrick mahomes performance it
wasn't
off the charts but incredibly efficient
26 attempts 21 completions 225 yards two
touchdowns no picks and and tyree kill
three catches for 20 yards usually
that's not a good formula for the chiefs
but last night it worked well and as you
said it worked well because of the
defense and they constantly harassed
josh allen aka your boy blue there he is
yeah here he is uh after the game
talking about what went wrong for his
team
i can't afford this team can't afford to
have me play poorly um you know early on
early on just not being as accurate with
the ball as i should have been
making the right reads making the right
throws um
and we turned it on a little too late
there obviously
um but yeah you know 16 and 17 points is
not going to cut it in this league you
know but it didn't matter who we played
tonight
that's who we play or
that's how we play you know we're going
to struggle to win games so um
it is what it is right now we will learn
from this i'm obviously super frustrated
with myself and how i perform tonight
and i can't do that to this team so
you know i got to be better i will be
better
we always get caught up in the new
season and fascinated by the big
performances and we're ready to anoint
because we're excited yeah and josh
allen out of the gates first four games
mvp candidate not now not after what
happened last tuesday night in tennessee
and then last night at home against the
kansas city chiefs i mean we've seen the
decline and last night 14 completions on
27 attempts 122 yards two touchdowns of
pick
73.4 passer rating look at the first
four weeks chris versus the last two he
went from averaging 331.5 yards per game
to 192.5
yeah and that's one of the big reasons
why this team is where it currently is
you're throwing a bad defense i mean
look at the touchdowns 15 total
touchdowns down to four four turnovers
and two just in the last two games i
mean that this is a guy who
needs to have that defense needs to have
some rhythm on offense needs a running
game needs a running that you know
whatever the chiefs
did
to get le'veon bell yeah the bills
wanted him they wanted them sean
mcdermott was willing to say we're
interested right they could have used
him yeah because they just can't find a
running game this year anytime your
quarterbacks are leading russia that's
not a good thing well that's right he's
the most dangerous rusher on their team
every week i mean you know statistically
he's second in the season for rushing on
the football team but that's you know
sacks things like that to get taken away
i mean he's he's the danger that what
you just explained is the is the problem
i mean josh allen is the team i mean
that's what we're saying josh allen's
got to make it all go the defense stinks
it's all about the passing game and him
making it work and you know like he said
i mean he took it on the chest there
he's he he didn't play well enough early
enough to just kind of get them in a
rhythm get them going that way but it
was going to be tough sledding either
way it was you know it it's just it's a
lot on his shoulders to make big throws
always avoiding pressure in the pocket
doing things like that and he certainly
missed some throws early where you go oh
i don't know but i think the bills also
probably you got to realize something
last night too you know they tried to
kind of play a de facto like oh
we're going to kind of try to control
the clock and do that a little bit as
well because we don't want to get a
shootout and i just bills you got to get
in the shootout you don't have any other
way you're going to win games
they got their strength of their team is
their ability to put pressure on people
through josh allen in the passing game
so
you know yeah it was not his best night
he's gonna have to hear about the
accuracy thing again which hey i didn't
necessarily like that joe buck and troy
aikman made such a big thing about that
again they went back to three years ago
like when are we gonna get over it the
fact is right now he's a 70 thrower he's
a 67 percent thrower and probably
throwing the ball in the air more than
anybody else in football as far as
intended air yards i mean they uncork it
every play
you know so i just felt like that was a
little disservice to him as well because
yeah we're going to talk about
his scouting report when he came out of
college and where i had him and i'm
going to try to justify that there's
bias there i just i didn't like that
part of the show or the the start of the
game it bothered me what was baker
mayfield's and sam darnold scouting
report then if you're gonna talk kind of
trash josh allen to start the game and
try to justify somehow some way why he's
doing better uh as you could tell that
kind of ticked me off and troy aikman's
like my favorite quarterback ever other
than phil sims
i thought aaron rodgers was yeah well as
like like like as a kid when i was
rooting you know what i mean like when
my dad retired troy took the mantle of
like the guy i was like okay this is my
new you know substitute father here
where i'm gonna i'm invested in number
eight the dallas cowboys and i became a
cowboy fan there through like my middle
school high school years because of troy
aikman
and and here's the thing yeah it was a
very common narrative i just happened to
be the one who was talking about it last
night and i think any time we see a
regression back to where i thought a guy
was going to be you you do feel like
okay maybe i was right all along because
yeah i ultimately want to be right just
like you want to be right about lamar
jackson and you want to be right about
patrick mahomes as you were and dk
metcalf but i've been wrong too there's
been lots i've been wrong about you know
so right right right right right but
when but when you're wrong and then all
of a sudden the guy starts playing yeah
like your body was gonna play right
that's when it's human nature to come
out and say those things so i don't
really have a problem with it it's up to
josh allen to play better because he
knows what people are going to say if he
completes 50 of his passes uh-huh
there's that guy from wyoming don't
blame it on your receivers don't blame
it on the weather blame it on you
now here's the thing and and i
i know that there will be people say
you're making too much of it i don't
care i'm gonna say it last night we saw
for the first time the
bad body language stefan diggs and
that's a warning sign yeah for the
buffalo bills we saw it late in the game
you saw him
sashaying back to the line of scrimmage
when time was of the essence i mean what
the hell was he did you see that yeah
he's like walking back the clock's
ticking stefan but
we know that this happens from time to
time it's the obj factor when i'm
involved and or we're winning it's fine
when i'm not involved and we're losing
it's not fine and last night after what
happened last tuesday night in tennessee
and at two prime time games and to have
that happen that that's where we see him
kind of slip back into the guy the
vikings had to manage very carefully
chris yeah no no doubt i mean yep i saw
what you saw you're right and like a
little disappointing for a guy like
stefan diggs who we see at the super
bowl every year and we always he's so
caring i love him we love him awesome
he's one of our favorite guys he just he
he gets it he's very charismatic he's
funny he doesn't take himself too
seriously but yeah hey
it's it's it's a very common thing with
top end receivers in football and uh yes
i hope we don't see a whole lot of that
we saw the bills lose their cool in a
lot of ways last night with personal
fouls and things like that you know they
were getting bullied you know for lack
of a better phrase and it you know they
they didn't know what to do so they got
a little you know on defense upset and
chippy and things like that because they
were being pushed around and dominated
and sean mcdermott and his team they
probably they really haven't been
bullied like that since he's been the
head coach there and everything there
and it just i think it shows them
generally hey buffalo you're good you're
dangerous but there's another class of
football that you guys got to get up to
before you're playing with the big boys
like the tennessee titans and the chiefs
who i think we both agree are two of the
better teams in football if not one of
the top two or three
and i think it makes it even harder to
have the season start the way it did
and to start thinking hey we're pretty
good you know what this the
patriots down we're up we could be like
the patriots have been let's go out and
do it and then you get smacked down by
two of the elite teams in the conference
and you really have to go back and do
some soul searching they get and and you
know what
the the short week
sunday at the jets coming up this is the
don't lose two games right yeah don't
lose two games right like your minnesota
vikings don't take that seattle beat you
twice right exactly don't take a winless
team lightly don't think you're just
checking the box matt casey
jets fan is saying it's not happening
don't worry yeah but but still be on
guard because the patriots are on the
back end yeah this is the perfect trap
game the only problem is
this really you know they can't really
set the cheese on the trap uh in new
york with the jets but but this is one
where you got you got you got six days
five days now to turn it around and get
ready for the jets and then the patriots
and then the seahawks they could get
smackdown a couple more times here
coming up chris and you know what going
to play arizona yeah it's not going to
be a picnic they got some tough games
coming up still and there's a different
vibe around this team and they they
better process it quickly and figure out
who they are and what their ceiling is
and get there and it may just be that
they're at their ceiling and they're
just not ready to take the next step
yeah that's really cool our new little
thing there you see that the bingo thing
look you said something about the
schedule hey there it is what did i say
that's that's awesome
listen i i strenuously object because
talking about the schedule
contextualizes a season
yeah
okay whatever you say but yes you're
right they got some games coming up to
where
you know buffalo better buckle down
because yes the patriots twice the
seahawks the 49ers the steelers you know
the dolphins one more time we know
they're a better football team than what
they played earlier this year so they're
not out of the woods i don't think i
still look at them and think they're a
playoff caliber football team because of
that offense
but i do think the last two weeks where
maybe you might have thought oh could
they make some sort of crazy run and be
a super bowl contender uh that has
dashed away for sure in the last two
weeks by the way their defense has
looked and just how much pressure is on
the offense in some of these big games
for them to come through and kind of
make it all happen one last point from
last night's game and this
shows how much harder it is now to play
defense in the national football league
and i don't know if you saw what we
posted over the weekend there was audio
from lamar jackson from the week five
game against the bengals where
he got touched at the sideline
fell down drew a flag and he was mic'd
up admitting right he flopped right
admitting he flopped and got a free 15
yards well what do we see patrick holmes
do now he dances around the edge of the
sideline if you touch him he will flop
because there's a benefit we're not
criticizing if you can pick up 15 yards
of field position however you do it do
it but the problem is the flag comes out
so what do you do when the guy's dancing
around on the sideline because you know
if you hit him he's going to fall down
and you may get flagged and you know
it's not like the 70s where jack tatum
is going to say the hell with it i'm
going to run over there and i'm going to
flatten this guy so the quarterbacks
have a hell of an advantage we see it
time and again where they get near the
sidelines and the defenses become
paralyzed because they know
if i touch him and he goes down i'm
getting flagged i don't know what to do
how do i do this where do i go is he
stopping is he starting right and we saw
it and he was just like back and forward
and i've never seen the zigzagging along
the sideline the way my homes did it
last night but but that's where we now
are because if you do touch him and he
goes down you have to worry about giving
up 15 yards no no doubt mike you've been
calling this for two years now how
quarterbacks do this and we've seen it a
number of times over the last two years
where quarterbacks give you oh i'm aware
yeah i know i'm aware yeah right i mean
or give the you know they give the old
okeydoke where i'm about to just kind of
jog out of bounds and they realize
everybody pulls up and then they run up
the sidelines for like eight or ten more
yards i mean matt ryan week one last
year right falcons vikings that was the
first time i noticed and said hey this
is bs bs you know there's a there's a
there's a gentleman's agreement here
we're letting you run out of bounds
right you're going to like act like
you're stopping and take off for 10 more
yards well hey it's still football i i
it's still football it's very right
but that's a problem you go hit the guy
and he doesn't he doesn't get treated
like a running back that's where the
game needs to kind of figure out how
it's going to handle this right now it's
way too far on the side of protecting
the quarterbacks i agree and the defense
is at a huge disadvantage i agree and
especially now with the quarterbacks
just becoming more and more mobile like
mahomes and you know of course lamar
jackson's out of this world but we're
seeing guys it doesn't matter who it is
i mean ryan tannehill he could turn the
corner and run for a 30-yard touchdown
it's just it's it's to me it is it's bs
that way it's too hard to play defense
in the league right now let alone you
know at times they're not allowed to hit
people or do anything the offense lowers
their head and the defense just tries to
get lower to make the tackle and they
call the penalty on the defense but i do
think that brings up a a real point you
know we i feel like we kind of saw that
in the afc championship game run with
mahomes where you got close to this oh
yes we did right yes yes we did yes
you're trying to drag me back into that
yeah but
yes but it just shows you where football
is where and everybody is obsessed with
the quarterbacks and don't you touch the
quarterbacks well then don't run don't
run if you don't want the quarterbacks
to be touched and if you run be like
tyler murray we're going to talk about
that game coming up where you're aware
that i better get down because if i
don't somebody's going to hit me
if you're going to run the ball you're a
fair target no and you're right and
there's such a there's such a a point of
you know distressing it to the referees
from the nfl too to where they're way
over protective and mike yeah i know the
lamar jackson play you're talking about
last week mahomes flopped twice on the
sideline against the raiders and one of
them he got a 15-yard penalty the guy
basically just put his arm on him to
like oh hey i'm running out of bounds
and you're right there let me just put
my arm on your shoulder and he felt it
and he knew it and he was about a yard
out of bounds and he acted like he got
pushed and he threw his arms in the air
and they got 15 yards check it out it's
in the fourth quarter he does it right
then so it is going to become a thing
and
who is going to be that team who's going
to be that team
that finally that's huge unleashes me
about it it just says i'm done i know
well i'll say it over well who's it
going to be go ahead you know go ahead
who's it who's it gonna be that first
that defense where the coach goes if
he's close to the sideline
crush him act like he's dead derek henry
if he's if he's down by the one-yard
line it's me i know if he's down by the
one-yard line
crush him like bring the pain there's
your chance to hit him do those type of
things i know and i'm not saying to do
to any particular player but
at some point these defenses are going
to get sick of this crap and try to make
a point a little bit of not letting
these free yards to these running
quarterbacks all the time
well and and i could see the mindset
because if we're going to get 15 yards
anyway right we're touching the guy
down right let's make it worth it i mean
i you know and and and this is
20 years of understanding how these guys
think how they talk remember the audio
that cartoonish over the top crap from
greg williams in the locker room the
night before the saints 49ers playoff
game nearly a decade ago
that that that's that's bubbling around
out there and i just think the defenders
don't know what to do
and there is going to be a coach i agree
with you whether it's patrick holmes
lamar jackson kyler murray ryan
tannehill matt ryan whoever there's
going to be a coach that says we're done
with this yeah right we need some
clarity here and also you know haven't
they in other sports
adjusted to flopping by putting in
penalties for flopping i remember
basketball they did that in the early
90s yeah right and in soccer don't they
do that like if you're if you're taking
a dive trying to trying to draw a
penalty and it's obvious don't they
penalize you shouldn't that shouldn't
that be shouldn't there be something
like that if quarterbacks are going to
take flops and admit that they're
flopping i i'd like it i'd like them to
do something like that yeah i mean to
like what you said it's it's
it's a little bit of a below the belt
cheap shot to the rest of football
because you're right there's a little
bit of a gentleman's agreement hey
you're going out of bounds we know
you're the special quarterback we won't
do it but when they get like egg in
their face all the time where okay i
slowed down because the coaches always
tell me don't give them a free 15. and
then they're running up for a free 15
anyways because i've slowed down and i
didn't think they were gonna you know
all of a sudden do the old okie doke it
is a little bit of bull crap but we'll
see my money's on the ravens
i don't know the tv what the ravens
doing they're gonna teach them
no
no no but that would be the ultimate
irony and i think i'm using it properly
if they're quarterback who openly bl
bragged about flopping
if they're the team that ends up
deciding we're done with this we're
we're going to go ahead and take well
you know if we're going to get 15 yards
we're going to make it worth it but but
look we're not advocating it we're just
saying this is football
and once you become a runner you forfeit
all of the protections that quarterbacks
have and there's this extra protection
that the officials are providing to the
quarterbacks that isn't fair to the
defense it isn't fair to the game and
it's going too far when guys like lamar
jackson admit that they intentionally
flop to draw a 15-yard penalty and we
see it with guys like patrick mahomes
there's something out of whack and the
question is
how does he get back into balance that's
all we're saying right we're not
advocating for anything it's football
and if you're going to run the ball this
is part of the risk you assist
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports